[Musique]
les boutons des boutons encore des
boutons des petits des gros de toutes
les couleurs l'outil principal de cet
atelier dirigé par marion et sylvie
breton le duo i des textiles objectif
créer une oeuvre destinée à l'exposition
doudou prévue le 31 janvier 2018
l'idée étant de faire une pluie ça va
être une ensemble de films suspendu qui
vont tous être enfilé deux boutons donc
après c'est le rythme des boutons qui va
simuler cette impression débouté deux
choses qui tourne tentant le son pour la
pluie c'est bien un atelier
intergénérationnel jacqueline est venu
avec pablo âgé de 7 ans pendant qu'elle
trie les boutons par couleur son petit
fils commence déjà à les enfiler pour
créer des guirlandes va gérer pour
revient que les faisait tenez sur un fil
sans que sa descente et bas qu'il
fallait les mettre en å thomas g unit
avec mon petit fils parce que c'est un
garçon qui aime beaucoup bricolé des
combats dans la campagne payera matchs
du bout de bois ira ce dont je me suis
dit les boutons c'est peut-être il va
peut-être trouver quelque chose à faire
est effectivement ça a l'air du père il
est très content je riais d'un jour à
guyancourt en répétant le même mouvement
passer le fil dans les petites roues des
boutons des boutons toujours des boutons
[Musique]